so is Trump going to be a dictator he
was asked this question by Shan Hannity
here's the response you are promising
America tonight you would never abuse
power as retribution against anybody
except for day one except for he's going
crazy except for day one meaning I want
to close the border and I want to drill
drill that's not that's not
retribution I got I'm going to be I'm
going to be you know he keeps we love
this guy he says you're not going to be
a dictator are you I said no no no no
other than day one we're closing the
border and we're drilling drilling
drilling after that I'm not a dictator
okay this answer is the 2024 version of
it's just awfully good that someone with
the temperament of Donald Trump is not
in charge of the law in our country yeah
because you'd be in jail it's that quick
witted response that people aren't
taking totally seriously but they're not
not taking seriously I think this is a
perfect answer here